I said I'd let you get a head start on
me it's quite okay if you look at this
and think we're I don't know what to do
after all because it is despite how
similar the pieces are it can't be done
within quite a different way I actually
think the best way to do it is quite
different which is why this looks so
strange what have I done I've actually
not drawn the same components I started
with over here
what's different okay yes this this sky
over here I've drawn in downwards the
reason why is because Reilly think
that's something take away something I'm
actually thinking of this as something
and then I'm adding a negative thing so
that's why this whole thing is
underneath the axis the whole object is
negative okay and these are what I'm
gonna add together okay so now I'm gonna
pick a couple of points and I'm gonna do
it the same way I did over there right
so for instance if I take this I want
you to again rehearse the same strategy
I used before if I take a piece of paper
and I cover up everything except for to
the right of that now here this is where
I started the biggest question what are
these two guys doing what are they doing
to the buck what are they doing with
their buckets of water can you describe
to me what's happening yeah very good
one guy once the UM once the water
levels rise the other one wants the
water level to drop someone's putting in
and someone's taking yeah which one's
winning which one is doing it father
now this the sort of net effect comes
from when you put them together this
grading is one in this great is negative
one hold on a second I saw this before
tonight where did I see it before in
which domain I started in this
in-between zone remember that granny one
great negative one okay so since they
exactly balance out the net result will
be the water level stays exactly the
same
do you agree with that just like it deep
here okay so therefore I'm just gonna do
a horizontal wife okay I suppose you
could think of it a bit like a tug of
war if you wanted if you prefer that
analogy you see you just want to plug it
down and this one's tugging up but they
are tugging at exactly the same rate so
therefore they don't go anywhere for
stalemate or that would someone like to
suggest me another region another domain
to look at now that I look to the right
of x equals range where else could L oh
yeah yeah fantastic so you can see I've
got more that's the same scenario
happening on the opposite side of the
graph do you see that except if I draw
again I forgot to draw zero if I draw my
vertical line at x equals negative one
it's going to be over there can anyone
tell me why it starts from here and not
there why am i doing it this way not
that way
what I'm doing I'm taking two objects
I'm adding them together I'm taking two
objects and everything together I want
you to look at everything except for
where the graph is at x equals they can
form one of the graphs is zero the other
graph as it happens that must be
negative for why it was thinking before
okay zero if you add that to negative
four
you're gonna get making it fall right
you're not gonna get zero so that's why
I'm down here in the same way over on
this side I'm adding two objects
together
what is zero there is y equals zero and
the other one is 4 so 0 plus 4 is 4
that's why I'm up there okay are you
with me so now what's happening on the
left-hand side what's happening to this
little ball they're going to be again
exactly balanced do you see that so I'm
gonna draw another horizontal horizontal
dish okay all right last pot I want you
to cover everything else we've drawn to
the right we've drawn to the left
what's happening in between not just on
a parallel but they're both going up
right so just like in this scenario here
remember on the right hand side they
were both going up right so the net
result was you're pouring water in your
friend pouring water in so together the
one that was gonna rise much faster it's
going to rise exactly exactly that fast
okay and you can go ahead and you can
check the algebra what's the equation of
this branch over here this right hand
side y equals x plus 1 is it 10 but not
the equation of this branch down here Y
it was one have a look
is it going up or down this puppy up is
it going up or down it's going up right
it's increasing we always read from left
to right so this is going to be X minus
3 when you add these two together if you
add this component and this component to
watch what happens Y is going to equal
to X plus 1 plus X minus 3 what happens
to the exit look there's that grade of 2
that you were expecting what happens to
the constant values you're gonna get
minus 2 which I hope your grass a little
better than mine but it should be
somewhere in there ok so both of these
both of these here they look weird and
wonderful oh yeah this is um this is
your 11 math now okay it is a bit
strange that you have to go through each
part and be individually about what each
one is doing but if you draw yourself a
good graph while that's accurate use a
ruler and it's big enough you can see
what the geometry is doing and you can
draw anything using that structure using
that principle ok